I just woke up so I I'm late I'm you
know I'm in a foggy foggy state of not
being here but be like I'm I'm branding
it right now Oh see you organ I'm
working right now yeah yeah
as we on you you're on stops go ahead
five four three two
stop sign ain't nothing but an octagon
an octagon and can tell me what to do
[Laughter]
Franken comedy he's thick and he's good
listen I'm not gonna say talk to you yet
all right so I just woke up I have to
introduce and I have to do something now
over the years of being um the celeb
King and being a leader being a hero to
many and also being not to some yeah not
a hero
yeah I've developed certain things to
survive in life and I've I've developed
a thing called the troll I the troll I
yes the troll I is your truth and a lie
at the same time and I'm gonna call it
because I have to [ __ ] do Eric
Griffin's podcast you're gonna do it
no it's Century City right after this
and I'm gonna get out of it because I
want to show you this new word called
the troll I can't do it show us no I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
cuz I had two hours of sleep I'm so
[ __ ] tired
alright so Eric Griffin and then you
come in here no do you location with you
locations shaming you location Shammi
because I don't live in a fancy house
like all your fancy friends like Joe
Rogan and everybody right you come in
here you I [ __ ] my girls come in here
yummy
you know you're putting your heat in and
I don't want it don't put your heater no
he all right so I'm gonna just I'm
telling you I know I gotta call Eric cuz
he's really looking forward to it and
then and if you laugh he's gonna know
right so you pretend don't tell him I'm
here I'm not gonna I don't wanna be
associated with this all right okay okay
yeah just tell me good hey man um
is there any way to push today or not
because something bad happen my favorite
uncle died not being real are you
talking about
no but are you going on this weekend you
see you're in town this weekend let's do
Thursday anytime Thursday I'll even get
up early I love you oh thank you man I'm
just devastated okay bye my favorite
uncle did die a long time ago though huh
bow the way long time
so that's thank you oh thank you July so
your July you're not right I'm not
allowed to hold up in court right thank
you
inside you approve up thank you and I'm
gonna steal your steal cuz I gave it to
you for free
I'm teaching you your move you're
dropping it is my move it is my move and
I need crazy
[Music]